[Musique]
richard berry est à 70 ans l'un des plus
grands noms du théâtre et du cinéma en
france ce sera l'apocalypse arnaquer
avec près de 80 films en tant que
comédien il est présent sur nos écrans
depuis 1972 notamment célèbre pour ses
rôles dans le grand pardon l'union
sacrée et [ __ ] douce
il est aussi connu pour ses talents de
réalisateur côté vie privée il aura sa
picholine en 1976 avec sa première femme
catherine hiégel puis livré une relation
tumultueuse pendant deux ans avec jeane
manson de 1984 à 1986
jessica fort de laurence ferrari il
enchaînera ensuite des relations plus ou
moins longue
il est aujourd'hui en couple avec pascal
louanges avec qui il a une fille en 2014
milla alors on parle de richard berry et
jean manson alors jean manson ses démons
chanteuse aussi un vois la magnifique et
les faits reprochés sont montrés donc au
début des années 80 alors que l'acteur
était marié à jeane manson
on vous explique tout leur relation déjà
pour que vous compreniez bien toute la
sphère regarde ça va partir
les catherine hiégel accuse ouvertement
son père mais aussi la chanteuse
américaine jeane manson d'inceste c'est
entre 1984 et 1986 que richard berry
jean manson il une histoire d'amour et
se marie une histoire courte et
difficile qui se terminera au bout de
deux ans par un divorce
pour jean cette relation conflictuelle
n'est pas un souvenir facile c'est
durant cette période que se serait passé
l'effet d'un cesse dénoncée par coline à
l'heure actuelle l'ex couple dément les
faits
justement que reproche-t-on à richard
berry et jeane manson et bien colline
berry la fille aînée de richard berry a
porté plainte contre son père mais aussi
contre jeane manson sa belle-mère pour
inceste viol agressions sexuelles et
corruption de mineurs petit récap de
cette affaire c'est sa fille coline
aujourd'hui âgé de 45 ans qui a décidé
de dénoncer les agressions dont elle
aurait été victime enfant de la part de
son père richard berry de sa belle-mère
de l'époque la chanteuse jeane manson 35
ans après les faits la fille de l'acteur
a décidé de sortir de son silence et de
dire sa vérité est là tu son père et sa
compagne de l'époque d'un cesse
lorsqu'elle était enfant entre ces huit
et dix ans elle a décidé de porter
plainte contre l'acteur de 70 ans pour
viols agressions sexuelles et corruption
de mineurs alors cette affaire a
visiblement divisé d'ailleurs le clan
berry d'un côté on retrouve richard
berry sa fille joséphine jeane manson et
de l'autre côté
coline berry sa mère bien entendu
catherine hiegel et marilou berry la
nièce de richard berry regarder parce
que les clauses sont vraiment divisé et
on aura dans un instinct donc l'avocat
de jean médecin est la première réaction
de jeane manson qu'il a donnée pour
touche pas vous passe rien bonjour à
vous qui m'écoutent et et syrie j'aurais
plutôt préféré vous parler des choses
plus créatif mais je voudrais aussi dire
que le public français sont mes amis
depuis fort longtemps et ma famille qui
est solidaire et comprend les
difficultés de ces moments pénibles pour
ma défense face à des mensonges devant
les médias vous savez je vécu très peu
de temps avec richard berry entre 83 et
85 et je n'ai pas entendu ni parlé avec
sa fille depuis 35 ans hormis un
déjeuner l'an passé j'ai pris
connaissance de la plainte malheureuse
de la fille de richard et par la même
occasion de ma relation avec son père
je suis horrifié par ces propos car
durant le peu de temps que j'ai passé
avec elle en aucune moment et j'ai eu
connaissance de fête à caractère
incestueux de la part de richard
aujourd'hui je dénonce cette inquisition
malsaine c'est une affaire entre père et
fille qui n'arrive pas à se comprendre
ce n'est pas mon histoire voici mes amis
c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire et à
bientôt je l'espère dans de meilleures
conditions
keane on espère aussi dit raymond
chanteuse un ballon incroyable et c'est
vrai que quand on entend ces mots alors
forcément nous on ne peut pas juger
cette affaire célébrer notre histoire
voilà ça n'est pas notre histoire mais
c'est vrai que cette histoire elle nous
a tous n'ont rien retourner aujourd'hui
on va voir l'avocat de jeane manson
belle-mère de collines et ex épouse de
richard berry avec nous en exclusivité
dans un instant en fait stagner voulait
dire quelque chose mais au moins je veux
dire déjà que l ordre des réseaux
sociaux malheureusement n'y a aucun
respect de la présomption d'innocence
moi j'ai vu des horreurs cet après midi
passé sur les réseaux sociaux je pense
qu'il faut laisser quand même la justice
faire son travail
en tout cas ce qu'a fait richard berry
le clan richard berry en termes de
communication je pense c'est ce qu'il
faut faire c'est à dire qu'ils ont réagi
immédiatement on a ce document qu'on
vient de diffuser et gerber il a réagi
sur son compte instagram
immédiatement on a la réponse de richard
berry rien entendu et lui en fait il
sous-entend que ces accusations et ne
date pas d'hier et qui avait d'autres
accusations mais que sa fille aurait
surfer sur le mouvement mito 1 c'est ce
qui a été lancé par le livre de camille
kouchner et aurait un peu dévié
l'histoire pour la raccorder à de
l'inceste donc au moins il a réagi
immédiatement et je pense qu'en termes
de communication c'est ce qu'il faut
faire alors richard berry dément les
accusations dit je démens de toutes mes
forces et sans ambiguïté ces accusations
immonde
je n'ai jamais eu de relation déplacée
ou incestueuses avec colleen ni avec
aucun de mes enfants
ces allégations sont fausses selon
l'acteur les premières accusations
d'inceste de sa fille rom ont trait à 7
ans des accusations il ya sept ans elle
pour la première fois fait allusion au
fait qu'elle aurait été abusé son récit
a évolué avec le temps il a été démentie
renouvelée et enrichie par elle au gré
des interlocuteurs ou de l'actualité
bernard montiel qualité il faudrait
savoir quelle était la relation entre
pat richard berry et sa fille compliqué
mais il s'entendait très bien
ça fait bizarre même voyez en ont c'est
parce qu'on parlait depuis des années
les animaux non mais je veux dire qu'à
l'époque quand il vivait notamment avec
jeane manson jim henson avait déjà une
fille qui s'appelait shirel elle aussi
oui avec un autre mariage est d'ailleurs
les deux filles dorment et ensemble ils
étaient très très très très amis donc
c'est très curieux qu'il en soit arrivé
là alors ce qu'on a su poser si vous
voulez par la suite c'est
qu'effectivement elle même était devenue
maman qu'un moment elle et elle était
enceinte et au même moment
richard berry aussi avec sa nouvelle
compagne attendait mais également un
enfant et que ça elle aurait très mal
vécu il paraît que quand elle était
jeune fille elle avait une passion pour
son père mais une passion qui peut-être
dévorante à la limite de la jalousie
voyez de la nouvelle compagne à chaque
fois et ça à chaque fois ça la fait
souffrir
alors j'y vais apprendre à l'avocat
maître jacques vernier richard berry a
été très transparent sur cette affaire
parce que il dit les faits sont
prescrits
mais malgré tout je demande que la
justice fasse tout son travail
c'est vrai que les faits sont prescrits
alors il faut savoir que la plainte a
été déposée pour viol sur mineur de 15
ans par ascendant on ne dépose pas une
plainte pour inceste puisque l'inceste
mais entrée dans le code pénal qu'en
2010 d'axa s'est passé potentiellement
bien avant mais la justice a ouvert une
enquête préliminaire qui devra dire s'il
y avait éventuellement d'autres victimes
et si les faits ont perduré
c'est pour ça que même si les faits sont
prescrits il ya une enquête qui est
ouverte alors on à m jacques verdier
avec nous merci de réagir en exclusivité
pour touche pas à mon poste merci d'être
là
m richard berry donc l'ex mari de jeane
manson est donc accusé de faits
incestueux par sa fille aînée colline à
l'époque où jean manson ce que vous êtes
l'avocat de jean manson était sa
compagne
on a eu sa réaction à jeane manson
comment la réagi face à ces accusations
elle vous appelle vous a dit quoi
extrêmement compliqué à gérer
la première la première émotion c'est
bien sûr d'être effaré consterné
abassourdi par de tels propos qui sont
tenus à son encontre et de la généralité
des accusations à caractère
incestueux qui sont parmi les plus sûrs
et plus révulsante lapierre bassesse qui
soit et qui relève de pratiques de gens
qui m'ont abandonné tout sens moral
donc bien sûr jeane manson est effondré
de cette situation effrondré de voir que
des puissent être impliqués dans un
rapport familiale alors même que
celui-ci remonte déjà à 35 ans alors m
juste à la porte et plantes colline
comment on peut aller aussi loin sur des
faits qui seraient fond c'est la
question que tout le monde s'est posé
aujourd'hui moi je me fais l'avocat des
réseaux sociaux des ce que pensent les
gens
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça parce
que c'est très compliqué parce que cette
plainte au marignan je ne la connais pas
on en est d'informer uniquement par la
presse moi à ce jour je sais qu'il y
aurait il une plainte déposée à
l'encontre de richard kelly justifiant
d'une enquête préliminaire par le
parquet mais en ce qui concerne la
manson je ne sais pas s'il y avait
véritablement une plainte qui a été
déposée donc on ne sait pas si elle est
associée à la plainte déposée à
l'encontre de richard berry si elle sera
simplement entendu comme témoin ou si il
y à des allégations précises qui seront
portées à son encontre de toute façon
sur des faits inexistants je ne vois pas
trop ce qu'elle sera là le support de
cette place alors quelle relation à
l'entretien jean manson avec avec
colleen as parlé encore ou pas du tout
non non non et ne se parlaient plus ce
n'est pas que l qu'elle n'avait qu'elle
s'était brouillé simplement la vie les a
séparés le ti de richard berry
appartient à la relation entre jean
manson les richard berry c'était il ya
35 ans depuis lors il n'ya plus le
contact
à l'exception d'un repas l'an passé où
en 2006 9 mai c'est le seul contact qui
qui est exister entre ces deux personnes
alors est ce qu'elle est toujours en
contact avec richard berry jean manson
aujourd'hui est ce qu ils se sont
appelés aujourd'hui est ce qu'ils se
sont parlés non non non non il n'y a pas
de contacts directs actuellement
ce sont même pas parler d'histoire ils
ont trahi changer tous les deux
aujourd'hui non ils n'ont pas changé sa
position je fais on répond à sa manière
moi je réponds pour jean ça ne ce soir
dans votre émission
richard berry a répondu sur les réseaux
sociaux donc chacun mène sa voix mais il
n'est pas de communication jusqu'à
présent sur ce sujet d'accord alors vous
avez vu que coline suite à la réaction
de son père coline a décidé de sortir du
silence publiquement et a maintenu ses
accusations elle reproche à son père de
l'avoir fait participer à des jeux
sexuels
ses sept enfants celle qui était
embrassé par son père sur la bouche est
la langue celle avec qui son père n'a
jamais eu la moindre pudeur
celle qui a dû participer à des jeux
sexuels dans un contexte de violence
conjugale notoire c'est elle qui a
déposé plainte
elle a également tenu à expliquer que sa
version des faits n'avait jamais évolué
contrairement à ce que dit son père mais
à ma narration des faits n'a jamais
varié nombre de témoignages peuvent être
fournies au soutien de cette assertion
notamment au sein de ma propre famille
elle met également en cause le
comportement de son père vis-à-vis de
cette affaire qui aurait tout fait pour
lui mettre la pression et préserver son
image sur qui a évolué au fil du temps
c'est son attitude de la violence
première il est ensuite passé à la
sollicitation moi pour que je passe
l'eponge ou ne la fasse pas ne le fasse
pas passer pour un pédocriminels l'image
voilà ce qui importe pour certains plus
que tout 10 27 comment elle réagit quant
à l'entente tout ça si vous voulez on
est dans une dans une espèce
d'aggravation de l'accusation et cela
sous-tend s'ils voulaient effectivement
une espèce d'évolution progressive des
accusations qui sont portées contre
riche très riche
ces accusations passant de simples
allégations dans un premier temps
jusqu'à jusqu'aux propos que vous venez
de donner
je pense que richard berry s'est très
clairement exprimée de soutenu la sueur
justement le fait que bien dans le temps
à partir
deux en arrière d'une période de six ans
et du début de la dégradation des
relations entre richard et sa fille et
bien il ya eu une montée en puissance si
on peut dire qu'il est aujourd'hui avec
cette plainte qui a été déposée dont on
ne connaît pas le texte est désormais
avec cette réaction où on voit de plus
en plus de mots violents qui sont
utilisés rencontre de son père est
peut-être un autre même de jeane manson
merci en tout cas m e jacques verdier
d'avoir est avec nous ce soir
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
ajouter ce soir peut-être n'ont rien de
plus si vous voulez simplement que je
représente une artiste extrêmement connu
une artiste qui aujourd'hui est meurtri
qui est blessé qui est dans la lah cause
de façon inconditionnelle au profit des
enfants comme elle l'est au profit des
femmes donc vous doutez bien que c'est
quelque chose qui est extrêmement mal
vécu ce qu'elle souhaite désormais c'est
que la justice qui avait saisi à même
son oeuvre et que la vérité éclate enfin
et sur ce résultat judiciaire qui a
trahi qui nous sautent aura bien sûr et
je l'espère pour monsieur veris il ya
dieu
eh bien nous y reviendrons devant votre
émission pour et pour l discuter d'autre
chose que de ces masses considération